good afternoon everyone it is a real
pleasure to be here with prime minister
karens in canada
you welcomed me cristianos to latvia
just a few months ago back in march
and i'm honored to be able to welcome
you here to canada in such a beautiful
sunny day
it was a really good productive meeting
we had
it just now we reaffirmed the strong and
deep ties between our countries we're
both steadfast supporters of ukraine and
we discussed further military support
that we can
today prime minister karen and i also
discussed how we can continue
strengthening nato's deterrence and
defense measures along europe's eastern
flank
as you know canada leads the nato battle
group based in latvia which i had the
chance to visit back in march at camp
adazi
currently 695
canadian armed forces women and men are
deployed in latvia
today
i am very pleased to announce that we
will be deploying a general and six
staff officers to nato's multinational
division north headquarters in adazi
they'll be part of a first of its kind
unit in the northern baltic sea region
to help plan coordinate and integrate
regional military activities
it'll serve as a continued and important
part of our enhancements to nato's
defense and deterrence capabilities
this is something
latvia had actually asked canada to
provide to continue assisting in the
region we talked about it a fair bit uh
just a few months ago so together
through our collective strength we will
continue to defend against threats to
democracy and global
stability over the weekend
i was in ukraine where i got to see
firsthand what attacks against democracy
and global stability looked like
i saw the devastation of earpin with
homes destroyed with neighborhoods
is
me despite the dark and brutal realities
of war
romania ukrainians continue to seek a
bright
free
democratic future
we will
together collectively be there to
support ukrainians as they defend
themselves against putin's illegal
invasion and we will be there
as the country
rebuilds afterwards
cristianos thank you so much for being
here today thank you for everything you
and your partners do to defend nate to
defend europe to defend democracy
ensembles
come in it's very good to see you here
today my friend
thank you very much justin it's
wonderful to be here in your wonderful
country and your wonderful capital on
such a warm if not hot uh sunny day
your role as a prime minister and your
role as as a leader of canada the
leadership role is very highly valued
not only in in my country throughout the
baltics and in europe as a whole
we
speak about
the basic values that we share freedom
democracy and the rule of law but what's
important is that we're willing to back
up
our support of these values with uh
strength and might if necessary and the
world unfortunately has changed that we
see that it no longer is enough to
simply speak about our way of life but
we have to be willing to invest into
increasing our military capability to
def
to actually defend our way of life
indeed
in latvia as you know we are currently
investing 2.2 percent of our gdp on
defense we've made a decision together
as as our neighbors the estonians and
lithuanians to move that in the next
coming three years to two and a half
percent so we are certainly investing in
our own defense but we also
fully understand and appreciate that our
defense
works as part of a collective defense
and canada's leading role in the efp in
latvia has been crucial
now the decision that you've taken today
of
further strengthening the multinational
division north which is currently based
in riga
is a very very big decision indeed
because in the baltics uh what we see is
the proportional response to putin's war
in ukraine
is
uh and this is what we need to discuss
and
agree upon politically in madrid in the
coming in about a month and a half
is
a robust
nato presence which has divisional uh
capabilities to ensure that an attack
from russia would never occur that it
would uh just make no sense at all so
the decision that you have made is a
step absolutely in the right direction
and is very very highly appreciated uh
indeed
so
maybe sometimes people say
is it right or is it worth it
to increase
investments into defense
and i am absolutely convinced that for
us as freedom-loving nato partners it's
much much cheaper to invest in a timely
manner in our defense than having to
deal with the potential very negative
consequences of not having made that
investment which would be extremely
extremely expensive uh indeed so your
decision and your commitment is is spot
on uh and and uh very very appreciated
um we both share the commitment to
supporting ukraine
our country was supplying arms to
ukraine even before february 24th
we understand that ukrainians today are
fighting and dying for the values that
we all share
freedom democracy and the rule of law
and we have to do everything to continue
to support ukraine because supporting
ukraine is essentially supporting
ourselves and
supporting our way of life and helping
the ukrainians
as democracies
i think it's extremely important that we
not be afraid to be strong
through combined strength we can
maintain our values
and protect our freedom-loving way of
life so thank you once again justin for
the wonderful meeting
it's always a pleasure to look for ways
how
canada and latvia can strengthen are
already very close and very good ties
thank you very much thank you chris
you'll see uh news of all maintenance
we now have 20 minutes for a one
question one follow-up we will start
with kevin as the first question hi
kevin gallagher ctv national news this
question is for both prime ministers
prime minister karns you're on ctv's
power play yesterday and you talked
about moving towards more preventative
posture in the baltics
uh where laffy is no longer a quote
tripwire but rather
any russian aggression is stopped before
they cross into nato territory can you
expand on what that means and i'd like
to know if you've spoken to prime
minister trudeau about this if you've
asked mr trudeau perhaps you can tell us
if you're going to support that type of
initiative
in madrid
uh thank you very much for the question
uh so
the tripwire defense uh is is a is is a
uh approach that was taken five years
ago
that
would entail that if there were an
attack which seemed quite remote that
that russia would actually attack any
neighboring country
that nato would then have the ability to
slow down the attack and then to
reinforce and to
retake
potential territory that is lost what
we've seen since february 24th
is that russia is unfortunately indeed
willing to attack a peaceful neighbor in
this case ukraine of course ukraine is
not in nato but uh still the fact that
uh
that kind of uh uh uh an attack could
happen is is now not theoretical it's
unfortunately very very real and what we
are arguing what we have also i i i we
did discuss is that the approach or the
proper response of nato is a political
decision to
in a sense up our capabilities to lower
the probability of any such attack in
the baltics and so when we speak of
divisional capabilities this entails a
full range of of
how should we say tools to be able to
adequately defend ourselves which is a
little higher uh a defense posture that
we have today
our country is investing into our own
defense and will be increasing the
number of soldiers and the the types of
equipment that they have that's a given
canada has already made a fantastic
commitment and a i mean not only in
prolonging uh its commitment to lead the
efp and sending additional soldiers and
equipment but today also to start
manning multi-divisional
headquarters north and it's actually
through the divisional headquarters and
beefing up now the divisional level that
is a step in the absolute right
direction so we need to send it's
primarily a message to moscow and to
putin that we are dead serious about
defending ourselves
don't even think about coming this way
i think the framework the frame to
remember for people is article 5 means
article 5 of nato means that
uh
if
the russians for example were to advance
even a single kilometer into latvian
territory
the entirety of nato would mobilize
in defense
but given the situation post-crimea it
was determined that it would be on top
of the article 5 guaranteed that is
strong and there
it would be
good
to have an enhanced forward presence to
send
canadians
and other nato allies
on the ground in the baltic states to
demonstrate that not just article 5 is
protecting them
but
valiant troops from the collective nato
nato alliance
and that has held and been extremely
effective and extremely important for
many years
but ukraine
and russia's illegal invasion of ukraine
showed two things
first of all showed that russia is
willing
to make terrible strategic mistakes and
act against all
reasonable assumptions
and
miscalculate so much that they thought
that invading ukraine would be easy and
would be met by
little coordinated response from nato
countries and other friends
well they were terribly wrong on that
but they did it anyway
and the other thing that has given
people pause
is bucha
is the atrocities that russians are
committing
in territory they occupy
and the idea that that there would be
even
a an understanding that
you know the russians could advance but
then we'd come in and push them back
as something that is in any way
acceptable would
is something we have to recalculate so
these are discussions that we will be
having uh up until and at madrid on how
to demonstrate
what we have been demonstrating for you
know the past uh 75 days since uh
february uh 24th and russia's illegal
invasion of ukraine
which is that democracies
are willing to stand up
and fight for their principles their
values
not escalate but be absolutely steadfast
in the values that we believe in
with
friends who are democracies like ukraine
but even more so
than friends and allies in the nato
alliance like latvia
for a follow uh prime minister karns in
your opening statements you talked about
how you're upping your defense spending
above two percent of course canada does
not meet that threshold we're below the
two percent gdp commitment so prime
minister trudeau what do you say to nato
allies when they ask you why canada does
not spend at the two percent
canada has continued to step up in every
single nato mission
that has ever been
canada has been part of
we're taking a leadership role in latvia
our capacity to deliver and to be there
on the ground is significant and
extraordinarily valuable to all our nato
allies but we recognize that the world
is changing we actually recognize the
world was changing a number of years ago
when we put forward our strong secure
and engaged plan
for the canadian military which
projects an increased
military spending of 70 percent
over the coming years
and in addition in this past budget we
invested a further eight billion dollars
towards defense spending so we will
continue to step up and make sure that
the women and men of the canadian armed
forces have the tools necessary to do
the work that canada needs them to do
and that quite frankly our nato allies
expect
america
good afternoon prime minister marika
walsh with the globe mail the globe mill
reported this week that afghans who
worked for canada's government in
afghanistan at the embassy as
interpreters are being tortured by the
taliban while they wait for your
government to bring them here what is
your response to this and why isn't your
government moving faster we've seen with
ukraine that you can
the reports we're seeing are
heartbreaking and horrific the fact that
family members and individuals who
supported canada in
our presence in afghanistan over many
years are specifically being targeted is
completely atrocious
we continue to be absolutely committed
to getting as many people out of
afghanistan as possible get them to
safety in canada we've actually
committed to over 40 000
afghan refugees coming to canada over
the coming years and we're working very
very hard on doing that
but as you bring up the comparison to
ukraine people need to understand
situations are very different from syria
to ukraine to afghanistan to different
places where we are busy welcoming
people the challenge in afghanistan is
uh we are we find it extraordinarily
difficult to ensure the proper security
checks are done within afghanistan
because
of the taliban
and we are working with the
international community to try and make
this an easier situation but we need to
continue to make sure that we are
keeping canadians safe while being open
and compassionate in welcoming and many
as many people as we possibly can as
quickly as possible we've welcomed well
over 12 000
people from afghanistan
since the beginning of the uh the
conflict uh or the the change in power
and we will continue to do everything we
can to get them here quicker so are you
saying to the people who are literally
living in terror and being tortured that
there is nothing more your government
can do to speed this up as i just said
we are doing
more we continue to work with friends
and allies because we understand the
difficulty of the plight they're in
this is a consequence of the fact that a
the taliban
basically a terrorist organization is
now in charge of afghanistan and are not
eager
to facilitate
the departure of
some of their best and brightest
to countries around the world like
canada and we will continue to work with
allies and partners in the region
continue to par work with
western and multilateral partners
to try and accelerate the process
because we know
how much we owe to
afghans who supported canadians while we
were there to build a better future for
them and their communities
it
brian platt with bloomberg um
what is your reaction to pierre paglia
promising to fire tiff macklin and just
in general the way the bank of canada
has been brought into the conservative
leadership race
canada and specifically canada's banking
system and more specifically
the bank of canada
is recognized as having one of the
strongest most stable
most reputable
banking systems in the world and
canada's central bank is highly
respected around the world as being a
strong institution
the independence
of the bank of canada from the
government of the day
is a really important principle that
ensures
the stability and the good reputation of
canada in international economic
circuits
in international economic circles
it is something that is a source of
pride and a source of stability not just
for canadians but for canadian
businesses for canadian investors and
investments for investors coming into
canada to know that we have
a robust and rigorous central bank that
is independent from political
machinations or interference
the fact that
one of the leading candidates for the
conservative party of canada the leader
of the opposition seems to profoundly
either misunderstand that
or
not care about
the facts at all
is
uh somewhat disappointing in an era
where we need more responsible
leadership not less
but that it is is a decision obviously
for members of the conservative party to
weigh in on not for me
canada
[Music]
an international
one reason the bank of canada is in the
crosshairs right now is because
inflation is at a three decade high and
polls show this is the number one
economic concern of canadians right now
what's your own assessment of the bank
of canada's role in this do you and do
you think your own is this a problem for
the bank of canada primarily to solve or
does has your own government been too
slow to act on this as well i think
it is a reality that
millions of canadians all canadians are
facing right now rising costs of
groceries rising cost of gas
is the rising cost
in living
is a real challenge for canadians and
it's hurting families and causing a lot
of anxiety we understand that it's
something we all have to work on and
the government and the bank of canada
each have
important roles to play in that the bank
of canada
has control over interest rates and
monetary policy and ensures
that the decisions that are taken
are
going to lower inflation
on the government side we have a
responsibility to make sure we're doing
things that don't further enhance
inflation but that also
provide
respite and support for canadians and
that's where for example the indexing of
the canada child benefit to the cost of
living which is what we did a few years
ago will ensure that those hundreds of
dollars a month that show up in families
pockets uh in families bank accounts for
support with their kids will continue to
match the rising price of ghost
groceries
that's where we move forward on cutting
child care fees in half and
and bringing them down to ten dollars a
day over the coming years across the
country because that is something that
will save families thousands of dollars
a year
without necessarily contributing to
inflation because it actually leads to
more productivity and more people
entering the workforce so we have a
responsibility to be there to support
canadians the bank of canada has a
responsibility
to
fight inflation we do that independently
of each other but we can do it in a way
that does
result in better outcomes for canadians
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
canadian press i wanted to go back to
latvia um the prime minister
is here um and the baltic states are
currently asking
nato to both significantly expand
nato's military presence in the baltics
but also make it permanent will you
support will canada support that
at madrid summit
this is a conversation we had earlier we
recognized that the context has changed
where
years ago the article v
guarantee of nato was seen as enough to
deter russian aggression
but in a post-crimea world
uh we realized no we needed to actually
come together and put an enhanced
forward presence out of operation
reassurance on the ground of canadian
and spanish and
international sorry
multinational forces on the ground in
the baltic states
to demonstrate our steadfast commitment
to defense of all of our nato partners
and right now with russia displaying
spectacularly poor judgment in its
illegal invasion of ukraine we realize
that we may we do have to reassess
the risk posture and how much we need to
stand together
on
against potential russian incursions and
aggression and that is a conversation
that we are having on the way towards
towards madrid and we will certainly be
having next month at madrid at the nato
summit um canada is
is extremely proud of the work we've
been able to do on the ground in latvia
the
canadian troops no supplies no supply no
surprise to anyone here uh have been
exceptional and are uh extremely uh
warmly appreciated by the latvian uh
people for uh for being there and we
will always look to be able to do more
but we will do it in the context of uh
rigorous nato nato discussions
chris you want to say a few words uh no
i i i can
add to that that
what's mostly important
it's not
militarily speaking it's not in terms of
necessarily the number of soldiers but
the capabilities involved in the forward
presence so this is what needs to be
reassessed and what needs to be
updated
given the current circumstances and
what's extremely important is that we as
democratic countries as nato
send a very very clear signal to moscow
and to putin so that there could be
no room for a misunderstanding or a
false assumption that something would
indeed be easy and this is what uh is
important and what we've been discussing
and i wanted to ask about uh abortion uh
yesterday minister ian
said that you're keeping all of your
options on the table with regards to
protecting the ability to obtain an
abortion some have raised concerns that
legislation could in fact have the
opposite effect in some respects and i'm
wondering as you're considering whether
to legislate or not what are the factors
that you're currently taking into
consideration
obviously
the primary factor we take into
consideration is
every woman in canada should have a full
access to legal
safe
abortion services
and reproductive health services
wherever she is in the country
and
that these gains that we have that now
that right now for everyone in the
country not be rolled back by future
governments or
future decisions
the best way to do that as you've
pointed out there are discussions well
maybe it's legislation maybe it's not
legislation maybe it's leaving it in the
hands of the canadian medical
association that has ensured governance
over over these procedures for a long
time whereas a government like ours has
continued to as well
make real investments and
hold
provincial health systems to account
where they haven't been delivering uh
access proper access to people uh to to
women across the country so
there's lots to do there's lots to
continue to do that we have been doing
and i think this is a moment where
the
threat and the potential of an
overturning of roe versus wade in the
united states
has women
in canada indeed around the world very
worried that there is going to be a
rolling back of
significant gains that they have made
that we have all made in women's rights
so yes people are asking a lot of
questions about it people are very
concerned about it and i am
pleased to be able to repeat once again
that our government is unequivocal that
women have the freedom to choose and we
will
do
everything we can to ensure that that's
not a freedom that can be rolled back by
any future government last question from
evan good afternoon prime minister my
question first question is for you uh
today your country's parliament approved
the removal of a soviet war monument in
riga uh and i know that your country has
probably the largest russian population
ethnic russian population in nato could
you just tell us a bit about how the
ukraine war has affected unity in your
country how it's affected your russian
population and what it brought to latvia
all right thank you very much for the
question
uh so uh
the ukraine war
has changed
not only everything in the world also
the situation in our own country uh we
have a legacy of many russian speakers
in our country uh from the 1970s and
1980s in the process of of being
occupied were also in the being
russified and uh about 700 000 russian
migrants were moved russian-speaking
migrants were moved to latvia in that
time
since regaining independence the the the
proportion of of latvian speakers is
changing the entire situation in our
country has changed but we still have a
minority of russian speakers whose
families came whether from russia or
ukraine or belarus or kazakhstan or
azerbaijani from all over the former
soviet union who until the war started
on on the whole had very sympathetic
views towards
putin and the kremlin
as a as a result of history
family ties
traditions etc
as the war
started
what we've seen in our country is a
reassessment
of the former allegiance or you know the
moral or allegiance towards russia and
towards the kremlin in light of of the
actual
atrocities that are occurring in ukraine
as we see in butch as we see in mario
paul as we see in
her son as we see all over
the areas where the russian military has
been or is currently occupying and
according to the uh the latest uh polls
uh that the the number or the percentage
of our population
that still supports uh putin
has been
going down quite drastically and of the
entire population it is somewhere around
a four or five percent
so it's actually a small minority that
still feels somehow that putin is to be
supported my uh
guess i guess that's the best way to say
is that as time goes on this percentage
will be decreasing still further
so
the legacy of occupation is difficult
for any country to overcome in our case
50 years of occupation and now 32 years
of re of being independent once again
is is a process that we're going through
but
what putin is effectively doing
is probably counter to anything that he
imagined one
he has solidified the european union
two he has rejuvenated and solidified us
as nato member states giving us new
purpose and bringing countries like
canada and latvia closer together and
three he is not
uh uh
bringing citizens apart in my country
but actually having more and more uh
citizens who've been living in latvia
for 32 years who still had the feeling
that somehow but but russia is i mean
russia is a great country but moscow is
a is a you know putin is a great
government
reassessing that and realizing that it's
not that way so it is a process and
actually putin is having an effect that
i think that he never imagined which is
re-solidifying the democratic world and
actually in a country such as ours uh to
create a new understanding of what it is
to be latvian he did this in the ukraine
eight years ago and in a sense through
his uh uh occupation and illegal
incorporation into into russia of crimea
and his ongoing war on donbass
he has
forged in many ways a strong ukrainian
nation which is no longer
only ethnically based but there are many
russian speaking ukrainians who are 100
percent loyal to ukraine who maybe 10
years ago if they would have been polled
would have had equally warm feelings
towards russia
so this is one of the unexpected
effects of the war
thank you very much and prime minister
trudeau
your government has supported ukraine
going to the international criminal
court
but you've written three times to the
court to ask you to reject palestinian
cases
uh the killing of sharing abu agle has
led the palestinians to ask the icc
to investigate
will your government
maintain its position that the icc
should reject palestinian cases i think
there is no question that canada will
always
stand up for journalists and the
importance of the job they do
the killing of this journalist was
terrible
and we like many others are calling for
a full investigation into what happened
we're calling for a proper investigation
that concludes today's press conference
thank you